for many canadians losique
would already be one of the major causes of
fever when returning from the trip from the common
fever to the most virulent chikungunya
which causes severe joint pain
often militants and now
in addition canadian researchers have
established a  link with the spread of
meningitis fatal of course for people
of all stakes first thing we
noticed was the
relatively unexpected frequency of cases of jk
we found that leak a is a disease
reminiscent of the kit that comes to dare in
the  'a far west that only exists in paris
will be one of the major causes
identified for fever on return according to
doctor cédric kahn zuni
deputy director of the jenny macklin center for
tropical diseases who contributed to
the study pregnant women for  which
the consequences are disastrous
irreversible should therefore really
avoid traveling in waves of
current transmission we have
closed transmissions from by  sexual way
no interest in observing women in
celebration who was affected and two of
the three women actually in the cua
transmitted the virus to the ark then fetus
with ddd effect the congenital and
surprise if they wanted it  is that we
also observed among people who were
not pregnant but sick a rate of
complications the severe which were
much higher than
in France we offered the three
people with a
neurological condition including meningitis and 2 end of
drome of  guillain-barré
it's a work we call an
ascending paralysis which can even go so
far as to paralyze the
respiratory systems which require intensive care
what surprised us
that's for sure only 41 cases of vicat we
saw  strong st of consequence the fact
that it federates doctor pierre plourde
medical officer of health of the national board
of health of winnipeg collaborated in the
canadian research on the gie carte to
approximately 5% of the facts that she knows ven  ir
logical a form of paralysis which is
called guillain-barré le barrel
in adults and about 5% of cases or so
congenital transmission tomorrow a
new nest so that surprised us a
bit suggesting that there are rather fleas
probability of fresh  that she is doing towards
with this virus has compared it to other
similar viruses
Canadian researchers
thus renew the recommendations for
north-south travelers opted for the wearing of
long clothing protection against
mosquitoes and prevention by
condom of the  sexual transmission of the virus
up to six months
after your trip south
pregnant canadian women should
simply not travel
south east until further notice
this should include florida there is
not very  faithfully for the ten cases of there
is no vacation for the gicam which has
many companies working
on it dr karl weiss from the department of
microbiology and infectiology of
the hospital  l maisonneuve rosemont in
montreal
3 there are the usual precautions
to protect yourself from the bites of
infected mosquitoes shelter to try to
recreate mosquitoes and it works
but you have to know that the
cante problem is first and foremost a
problem for  the trams that are to be
talked about in the weeks or months
following the trip for the others there is
nothing really to worry about
if you don't have a ticket if you
don't have a plan to finally fall all
d  'having a baby and then
the enemy if you catch direct as
souletine in 70 68 years will be complete
symptomatic will have relatively
little impact on you but in the context
of a desired pregnancy and
pope's maple obviously creates problem  the good
news is that other canadian researchers are
working on the
development of a famous vaccine against the virus
to date in clinical trials in
canada we seem to reach 80%
success after two doses
we are moving forward now with
field testing after toriko name
just finished looking
at possible side effects
and immunogenicity we had to explain
gary cobain game who is a microbiologist
and director of the center's
infectious disease research center
quebec university hospital and that there is
adversity laval we have just done in a
year and a half what normally takes 7 to
8 years in fact we have seen it is very
encouraging
which is in view which is expanding by 160
people and we  should see
the trend but if internal of
any infection and puerto rico we will
perhaps have the chance to see the
first signs of effectiveness
a report by radio canada
international